bonsoir
programme première vente d'actions donc
pourri le masque depuis cinq ans on
comprend bien qu'il a vendu pour des
raisons d' impôts essentiellement
des raisons dépôt évidemment il y avait
aussi évidemment les options d'achat
d'actions la clé sur lequel ils devaient
agir
la question du sondage fait des bosses
denis parce qu'effectivement il ya le
programme politique démocrate veut taxer
milliards da et de rendre ça public est
une façon pour les noces de dire vous
voyez ce qui arrive quand on impose des
impôts milliardaire savent en effet sur
les actions que de petits épargnants
achètent également et donc peuvent aussi
perdre de l'argent donc un petit coup
était peut-être politique on sait que
masquer contre cette politique des
démocrates mais c'est effectivement mort
ce n'est pas en péril tesla non plus
n'ont exactement donc il ya toujours un
questionnement quand même aller à chaque
fois que jeff bezos ce que mark
zuckerberg que bill gates ou kate moss
décide de vendre des actions se
demandent toujours est-ce que ça va bien
l'entreprise mais dans ce cas ci c'est
pas le cas il une mosquée totalement
confiance en tesla oui mais pas
seulement mosca confiance le triplement
chuté depuis quelques jours mais c'est
un très petit complet au gain qui ont
été faits autres en termes de valeur
depuis plus d'un an depuis 2001 depuis
la fondation de tester si on veut l
entreprise aujourd'hui dix fois plus que
ce qu'elle valait ya deux ans quand même
pas à plaindre pour tout le monde qui
possède des actions qu'ils ont acheté
cette époque-là inclure un monsieur
muscle mais l'action qui baisse de 13 à
15% lundi mardi à la suite du tweet
delmas est-ce qu'il a le droit de faire
ça de publier une telle information sous
forme de questions mais ça s'appelle une
information comme quoi je vais vendre
des actions oui il le peut en faire sans
dire qu'il a le droit il ne porte pas le
droit de le faire disons le comme ça les
autorités financières américaines n'ont
pas agi en dise on dit qu'elle n'agirait
pas par apparaissent
c'est pas la première fois on le sait
masque est très actif sur twitter il a
tendance à dire des choses parce que
peut-être il ne devrait pas à divulguer
leurs sur twitter de temps en temps et à
cause de cela le passé s'était imposé
un comité de surveillance pour ses
produits par des gens au sein
département légal de tesla donc il ya
des gens qui filtrent c'est oui il ne
fait pas toujours il a fait pas toujours
confiant des fois ils tweetent sans
valeur ça leur parler mais jusqu'à
maintenant semble-t-il que tout ce qu'il
a fait autorisée il ya le constructeur
de camions reviennent camion électrique
qui a fait une entrée fracassante sur le
nasdaq hier
est ce que ces 29 % hier 22 %
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est totalement
spéculatifs cette évolution où il ya du
solide derrière cette entreprise là
c'est à mi-chemin entre les deux une
valeur astronomique pour un fabricant
qui n'a pas encore livré un véhicule
mais il ya promesse de livraison il doit
livrer 300 camions de livraison à amazon
avant la fin de l'année doit livrer dix
mille avant la fin de l'année prochaine
donc ce sont des ventes sur pratique un
objectif de 100 mille camions juste pour
amazon si la fin de la décennie donc une
clientèle une demande déjà des machines
qui permettent des usines son
introduction évidemment eu des délais ça
vaut pour lyon ça vaut pour revenir mais
ça vaut pour l'ensemble de l'industrie
automobile
mais évidemment lieu du spéculatif il ya
quelque chose dans les véhicules
électriques et est beaucoup les
investisseurs en ce moment ça profite de
tesla sa très jolie viennent d'autres
fabricants aussi qui émergent et qui
commence à s'installer dans ce créneau
là tandis que les constructeurs plus
traditionnelles telles affaires ce
village là donc pénale plus à profiter
de cette vague même si je le vend des
véhicules entre marc grand nombre ils
sont profitables l'autre un autre qu'on
surveille de près si lucide ou lucide
n'est ce pas
le seul moteur jeune compagnie
californienne le6 un peu un bébé tesla
ça fait quelques années qu'ils
développent une grosse berline
électrique qui a une fiche technique
assez impressionnant mais qui tarde elle
aussi est mise en marché elles aussi le
père qu'on commençait déjà commencé la
production et commence à vendre ou à se
livrer les premiers exemplaires aux
états unis mais aussi au canada ils ont
d'ailleurs un point de vente dans
l'ouest du pays est ce que ces
entreprises là vont faire concurrence à
tesla
oui absolument à tesla et aux autres
fabricants surtout dans le cas de lucie
de bréviandes vu le prix des produits on
parle de concurrence contre les
fabricants de luxe les marques de luxe
donc les marques surtout étrangères
importées européenne comme marc savard
est par exemple
tous ces gens là sont dans le même
marché n'est ce pas dans le marché des
voitures électriques c'est de votre
coach en qui soit perçu comme plus
luxueuses de chrome os une performance
des mesures et donc ils vont chercher
ses acheteurs le qui sont dans des plus
petits créneau de l'industrie mobile au
sens plus large mais qui sont des
créneaux très populaire les v ux les
groupes b us les camionnettes sont les
types de véhicule le plus vendu en
amérique du nord à l'actuel on assiste à
un fort mouvement donc vers la voiture
électrique vers l'électrification
mais les enjeux d'approvisionnement
freine quand même le marché on parlait
de lyon électrique ici au québec tout le
monde est touché
tout le monde est touché et ça dépasse
aussi secret automobile tout ce qui est
un composant électronique présentement
est susceptible d'être touchée par cette
espèce de rupture de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement qui est très
internationalisées il ya très peu de
jeunes qui font des semi conducteurs il
ya d'autres idées d'autres produits
d'autres matériaux qui sont en rupture
de stock les chaînes d'approvisionnement
surtout pas le transport électrique en
ce moment sont entrés d'être d'être
d'être construite d'état briquet et il
ya une très forte pression pour créer
des chaînes des ongs régional au sens
très large du terme par exemple
fabricants nord américains aimeraient
avoir jeûné provisionnement de
composants électriques entièrement
amérique du nord donc une opportunité à
saisir là pour bien des entreprises est
ce qu'on voit avec lyon et on le voit la
question de briand dans la fabrique
ainsi c'est qu'il nous demande très fort
mais il manque d'offres en ce moment
merci m mais qui n'a très intéressante
merci le plaisir ou pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]